[Musique]
c'est la fin idéale
j'attends pas son journal pour lire les
nouvelles j'espère qu'elles seront
sensationnel voyage grande porte à neuf
et benzéma son coup si les petits
commérages l'autre petit écho de la
forêt trouverait il y à toutes les
informations à chaque nouvelle édition
on n'a jamais de déception ça vous le
découvrirez dans le tue des cours de
l'offre
ou tu as tu un mademoiselle de la
cigogne veut faire un procès un proche
eh bien eh bien je me demande pourquoi
ils vous aussi certainement offertes et
les femmes mademoiselle madame wade
comme vous voilà enfin où diable est
chez vous doux et je faisais la sieste
l'un sieste vous n'avez pas honte et
nous la fait bien vous apprenez à
pertinent que je ne fais jamais la
sieste pour t'amuser de congé dans un
hamac
je ne suis pas couché je repousse donc
vous faites la sieste
sinon je vous dis que je repose si je
repose c'est que je sens que je vais
mourir
ah tiens pourquoi parce que je deviens
dingue tout est sombre autour de moi je
le vois plus les rayons du soleil les
mais moi je ne sais pourquoi vous croyez
médecin non mais je vois clair on a des
lunettes de soleil sous le bec à
l'entente
vous voyez tout en noir si j'ai mis des
lunettes de soleil ignorons c'est parce
que j'ai un abominable malbec est
pourquoi parce que depuis des jours et
des jours j'attends des nouvelles des
frères k score et je n'en puisse plus on
veut qu'à cela ne tienne je vais aller
voir où il entend débit hsip lelièvre
parti fort tu rates heures à l'atelier
des deux frères k stores alors que
penses tu de nos plein nous avons prévu
tous que mademoiselle de la cigogne et
demain au 10 avril
on se rate et jeu court vu mon travail
kevin j -p lelièvre reparti ventre à
terre chez mademoiselle de la cigogne
alors madame harel et 1 défaite
satisfaite mon pauvre ipred ont tort
taisez-vous pour m'installer dans la
forêt j'ai décidé de faire restaurer
cette maison de famille qui existe
depuis des siècles
oui vous osé appeler vieille baraque
un monument historique une maison qui
m'a vu naître dans cette comédie l onat
bali et les insultes mais c'est un beau
et noble inimaginable effroyable où je
sens que je vais me trouver mal desquels
une retrouver ses esprits mademoiselle
de la cigogne se rendit sans tarder chez
les deux frères castro
mais mademoiselle c'est vous qui nous
avez demandé toutes ces transformations
à la fois comme un sapin consolider les
fondations de votre médecin
apprenez jeunes incapables que ma maison
à résister aux tremblements de terre aux
tempêtes à la neige et au verglas
elle pourra très bien résisté à vos
travaux oui mais théoriquement pour
respecter nos pleins les plats
parlons-en
je n'en veux plus de mon plan est
pourquoi d'un parce que ma maison est
très bien comme et les si vous prétendez
la transformer et je vous attaquent en
dommages et intérêts quelques jours plus
tard pose en avoir longuement discuté
les deux frères caster aux airs se
présenter à la demeure de mademoiselle
de la cigogne qui yat il encore
eh bien nous avions travaillé nuit et
jour pour établi s'est plaint m
n'avons nous laisser en plan j'ai une
idée pour vos plans jeunes gens
ah oui faites en des cocottes en papier
voilà au mais ça ne se passera pas comme
ça nous allons vous faire un procès en
dommages intérêts et bien moi je vous en
ferai un autre un autre en dommages et
intérêts et pourquoi dans l'oise et me
demander des dommages et intérêts
maintenant vous pouvez disposer dans
votre intérêt d'ici des bancs cette
chaire cigogne est de très mauvaise foi
elle a bien tort
n'est ce pas chercher les femmes de
toute façon je vous donne rendez vous
pour une nouvelle édition du petit écho
de la forêt